ah
[Música]
y
en los eeuu la cifra de personas en
situación de pobreza pasó de 47 millones
en el mes de mayo justo cuando empezó la
pandemia a 55 millones al mes de octubre
esto según el más reciente informe
realizado por la universidad de columbia
las poblaciones más afectadas son las de
los latinos y afroamericanos que no
contaban con acceso a seguro médico pero
que también perdieron su trabajo y es
que esta cifra de aumento se registra
también porque los subsidios de ayuda
para la pandemia fueron suspendidos y el
congreso no ha logrado llegar a un
acuerdo para enviar un segundo paquete
de ayuda sobre todo a las personas que
antes de la pandemia enfrentaban
situaciones difíciles o no tenían
trabajo
[Música]
en argentina las cifras de pobreza e
indigencia han empeorado a la par de la
recesión que comenzó en el primer
semestre de 2018
el dato lo mide de forma semestral el
instituto nacional de estadística y
censos según ese organismo el porcentaje
de personas consideradas pobres no paró
de crecer desde el segundo semestre de
2017 cuando era de 25 7% poco más de un
cuarto de la población en el segundo
semestre de 2019 ya había subido a 35 5%
y en la primera mitad de 2020 alcanzó un
49 por ciento de la población por efecto
combinado de la persistente crisis
económica y de la pandemia de coke 19 lo
mismo ocurrió con la indigencia que pasó
de 4.8 por ciento en la segunda mitad de
2017 a 10,5 en el primer semestre de
2020 así hoy en argentina 11 7 millones
de personas son consideradas pobres y de
esas 3 millones son indigentes
[Música]
según el modelo de internacional future
es una plataforma de la universidad de
denver el 60 por ciento de la población
mundial quien vive bajo la línea de
pobreza se encuentra en áfrica
subshariana en 2020 los países más
afectados por la pobreza en el
continente son somalia república
centroafricana y la república
democrática del congo el ministro
sudafricano de salud zweli mkhize quien
por cierto ha dado positivo por corona
habidos en los últimos días dice que por
primera vez en décadas se está
aumentando el porcentaje de pobreza
extrema en el continente y esto podría
ascender hasta en un 9 por ciento
adicional dice que en los últimos seis
meses entre 26 y 39 millones de personas
han pasado de vivir en la pobreza
extrema y hay factores en el continente
que agravan este flagelo por ejemplo la
presencia de conflictos armados la
xenofobia en países como sudáfrica y las
restricciones al espacio cívico que
están poniendo algunos gobiernos y esto
afecta al trabajo que hacen algunas
organizaciones humanitarias tanto
locales como extranjeras que trabajan
para mitigar el impacto social que tiene
la pandemia en las poblaciones que más
lo necesitan
[Música]